compensation with President Putin in the
key Yahoo had a very good conversation
did you organize that call and do they
understand the problems we're causing
yeah yeah you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of there's so much
production nobody even knows what to do
with it that's how it's working and
Saudi Arabia and as you know Russia it's
well known that we're producing a lot
and they were perhaps fighting with each
other over the production and the amount
of oil being produced and frankly
there's not enough room to even store it
our storage is now full gonna be very
soon our strategic national storage is I
said there's a great time to fill it up
load it up with oil that frankly is at
pricing that nobody's ever seen before I
don't think we've seen this probably
since the 1950s that was with big
dollars so we'll see what happens the
conversation was very good they're
getting close to a deal that's OPEC and
many other countries outside of OPEC and
we'll see what happens you know I think
that we're getting along very well we
had a very good we had a very good call
I think it was a very good call we're
gonna see what happens but it was a very
good call they'll probably announce
something either today or tomorrow one
way or the other could be good could be
not so good but I think one way the
other